every time I think that I've had a crazy
year I lived the next year this is human
crazier from Kylie's secret pregnancy to
Tristan Thompson's cheating scandal et
is taking a look at the Kardashians
biggest moments of 2018 it's never a
dull moment
during the season 15 premiere of keeping
up a fight exploded between Kim and
Kourtney that seemed very real not just
for the cameras I need Kourtney to not
be so you know in with the stick up like
she's the least exciting to look at in
2018 Kim revealed to her sister Kendall
and Scott Disick that she was high on
ecstasy during two of pivotal moments in
her life I got married on ecstasy
know what you know the first time we did
it again I made a sex tape like
everything bad would happen you were
high an ex is sooner the sex tape
absolutely everyone knows it like my jaw
was shaking it was really tough for me
Khloe and Kylie revealed their secret
pregnancies after much speculation over
the year the sisters gave birth to baby
girls true and stormy within months of
one another I can't wait to be a mom
even though I'm 15
I would love some and Chloe endured a
boyfriend Tristan's cheating scandal
dazed before giving birth to their
daughter true I mean I think you you
just have to worry about yourself right
now and just be calm because I hear so
many horror stories and when you're
pregnant people for some reason tell you
more horror stories which is so mean
yes it's just all by the way by the way
yeah
your pregnancy has been the best kept
secret of our generation like I'm not
trying to keep a secret I'm really doing
this for myself like this never like
your friends deserve Awards 15 weeks now
so I'm 34 weeks today Kim and hubby
Kanye West also welcomed a baby via
surrogate giving st. and North a baby
sister Chicago
you know it's really different anyone
that says or thinks it's just the easy
way out is completely wrong yeah I think
it's so much harder to go through it
this way because you're not really in
control and you know obviously you pick
someone that you completely trust and
that you have a really good bond and
relationship with but it's still knowing
that I was able to carry my first two
babies and not you know my baby now that
is hard for me
so it's definitely a harder experience
than I anticipated just in the control
area and after almost two years of
dating Courtney called it quits on her
first public relationship since baby
daddy Scott Disick with Jonas Benjamin
who was 14 years her junior in August
and more professional affairs Kim and
Kourtney stepped into the political
realm in 2018 in a big way I have always
been the queen I was the original Queen
Courtney who is known for her natural
and healthy lifestyle went to Congress
on behalf of the Environmental Working
Group to fight for better clean beauty
and Kim aided in the release of prisoner
Alice Johnson a woman imprisoned for
more than 20 years for a first-time
nonviolent drug offense meeting with
President Trump on her behalf which was
a success the president just called me
[Music]
[Music]
you can't wait to meet your family the
Kardashian family will still be keeping
up with the kardashians in 2019
[Music]